Poor people stay poor because they want
a fast way to get rich. And instead, the
richest people that I know pick one of
these four paths, play it for a decade,
and then end up with more money than
everyone else that is just chasing
shortcuts. And just as a fun reminder
for you, no president, no economy is
going to make you rich. You have to do
that for yourself. So, in this video,
I'm going to show you the four paths to
mega money. And I'll show you how to
pick the right path at the right time
for you. Let's get into them. You've got
your money and your business. You've got
other people's money and other people's
businesses. And then permutations of
those. And so your money, your business,
right, is a bootstrapped business. If
you have other people's money and your
business, now you're raising capital.
If you have your money and other
people's businesses, now you're
investing. And then finally, you have
other people's money and other people's
businesses, which is fund management.
Now, to give you some proof points
around this, I actually looked up the
top 11 richest people currently on the
Forbes list, and I'm going to tell you
where they are. So you've got Elon Musk.
He's a raised capital guy. Almost every
single company he's had, he's ra ra ra
ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra
ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra raised
outside capital and then he's continued
to fund it and grow it. Larry Ellson
who's number two raised capital. Mark
Zuckerberg raised capital. Jeff Basos
raised capital. Larry Page raised
capital. Sergey Brin raised capital.
Steve Balmer bootstrapped. Microsoft was
bootstrapped. A lot of people don't know
that. Underneath of that you got Jensen
Wang raised capital. Warren Buffett
investing. Michael Dell bootstrapped.
The Waltons as in Walmart bootstrapped.
And so that's the top 11 wealthiest
people in the world. Now, you might have
noticed that fund management wasn't
there. If I go like six deeper, you'll
find people who did fund management.
Now, one of the interesting things about
each of these contracts is there's a
little bit of risk and there's a little
bit of trade-off with each of them. And
I personally have done one, two, three,
and four, believe it or not. And so,
I'll actually walk you through my own
examples and which one's right for you.
So, let's start with number one,
bootstrapped. Bootstrap just means that
you fund the business from your own
savings and cash flow. you have no
outside uh investors and you grow
through reinvesting your own profits.
You have a website and you've got a cell
phone and you've got skills and you
start trading one for the other, get a
little excess money, take that excess
money and then continue to build. Now,
typical examples for this are usually
lowcost businesses to start. A lot of
times that's services. So, agencies,
home service businesses, B2B services,
professional services, things like that.
Sometimes nowadays you can actually do
this with software. It didn't used to be
that way, but now it kind of is.
education businesses, uh, ecom brands,
if you do drop shipping, uh, if you
don't do drop shipping, you'll have to
front some capital in order to get the,
you know, first inventory started, uh,
local businesses, most normal companies.
Now, to be fair, that scope has
continued to broaden because the cost of
entering business is going to continue
to drop. Now, for me personally, um, my
first brick-and-mortar business was a
gym, and so that was bootstrapped. I
used the profits from that to start uh,
Prestige Labs, which is a supplement
company, which was bootstrapped. I
started Allen, which is a software
company, which is bootstrapped. Um and
so all those companies were
bootstrapped. Today acquisition.com is
taking some of that capital investing it
um into other people's businesses while
also having some companies that we start
denovo from our holdco which is kind of
semi bootstrapped and also kind of
reinvesting our own capital. So you can
see how some of these these these boxes
merge. Now who is this right for? So if
this is your first business I recommend
starting with bootstrapping. And the
main reason is just like you want to pay
off ignorance debt. The last thing you
want to do is take your you know your
friends and family's money and then lose
it because you don't know what you're
doing. That's my opinion. Everyone, you
know, your results may vary. You can
stick of the names on that list that I
mentioned. Jeff Bezos, the people that
he knew invested, Bill Gates, the people
uh I think he had rich parents. I'm sure
they helped him out in the beginning. I
don't know that the actual public
documentation of that, but I think he
had a little bit of help um in the
beginning there. But the thing here is
that like I don't think you're going to
want to go raise a ton of capital from
everyone, you know, maybe even VCs uh if
it's your first shot. Again, you know,
your results will vary. Your life is
unique. But the main thing is that
bootstrapped will typically be the
slowest of the four paths. And that is
usually because it takes money to grow.
And if you have to make the money to
grow, it's almost like having a car
factory built inside of the car. It's
very difficult to do. Humans do it. We
have human factories inside of our
humans. Weird stuff, right? Um but in in
in business design, it's much much more
difficult, right? It's slower to build
the capital reallocation machine while
also building the machine that makes the
capital to begin with. You kind of have
to have both. Now the main advantage of
this is that you keep the control and
the equity so you have a you know bigger
slice of the pie. You decide the pace
the strategy and ultimately you can exit
on your own time horizon or never exit
at all. Right? And the goal is that you
design a compounding vehicle which is
either recurring or reoccurring um
within the business and then you let
that over time do the heavy lifting.
That's the end goal. Now a lot of first
businesses don't have any of those
things but you you know buy a dollar
sell for two and you make money. There's
nothing wrong with that. Here are some
of the trade-offs. When you bootstrap,
you incur more debt than any other
vehicle. Now, you're like, "Wait a
second. I thought I was, you know, using
my own money to start this thing." Yes,
but you incur every other type of debt.
And often times, every other type of
debt is harder to pay off than money is.
So, what do I mean? If you're starting
with your own cash, it's very difficult
for you to attract like a star talent
team of 10 people that all need a
million dollars plus per year to work
and actually grow this thing. If you're
venturebacked, you can do that with some
stock and then also decent cash
compensation. And so that becomes harder
to do. So you incur lots of management
and leadership debt. If you like can't
get the high enough level of the
softwares that you need in order to
build your software company or whatever,
if you start low, you're going to have
some technical debt that might incur as
along the way. Same thing with your data
debt. So, you're going to have lots of
debts that money could have otherwise
solved for you, but you don't have money
as one of the things that you're in debt
for. Now, to be clear, there are pros
and cons there. Like, the pro is that
you can stay alive a lot longer because
you typically keep your cost basis a lot
lower. Uh the the downside is is that it
goes slower. And so, your capital
constraint will often times limit the
size of what you can pursue from day
one. If you wanted to start an AI
robotics business to go global, it would
be incredibly unlikely that you would
succeed because the amount of capital it
would they would cost to just build one
robot, let alone many robots as you
scale. And then you functionally
probably lose money on building that
first robot. And then after you lost
money that first robot, you'd some have
to get more money to then build more
robots. It's very hard to do without
outside injections of cash. And so this
box does constrain to a degree what
kinds of opportunities you can pursue.
And there's a reason that some of the
biggest people in the world start here,
which is a perfect segue to okay, so
what is other people's money into your
business. This is raising capital,
right? So you start and you run the
company, but you raise capital from
investors who buy a slice of equity to
fund the fast growth. Normal examples of
this are tech platforms, social
networks, marketplaces, manufacturing,
pharmaceuticals, where it t years and
years and years to get a drug passed and
then it makes money. Typically anything
that has huge amounts of upfront costs
then increasing margins or gross margins
later and or winner or take all dynamics
meaning you have to lose money for a
long time to get the whole market and
then all of a sudden you have a network
effect and then everyone buys from you.
Amazon famously lost money for like a
decade plus before they really started
turning a profit. Facebook too lost
money for a long time but they were
mapping networks. So who should take
this path? If you have a very big dream
of what you want to build and there's
functionally no way to make your thing
profitable without using other people's
money like as in like you will just you
know you're going to lose money for a
year two years 3 years in order to
actually have this thing work then you
have kind of like a predefined path that
you're going to have to raise capital.
So, I have experience with this because
school is venture-backed, right? And so,
we raise capital at school to continue
to grow the company and we're able to
give pricing, which is absolutely
absurd, like $9 a month, which by the
way is very little with inflation. Uh,
it's basically free uh in order to get
as many people who want to start a
business the all the tools they need to
do it. Now, the main advantage of this
is that you start with a bigger thing.
You can hire the top talent. You can
outspend competitors. You can be
negative in your acquisition cost. I
mean, you can lose money getting
customers, right? Uh you can build
infrastructure faster than you could
with your own cash alone. And on a
personal level, you can incur way less
personal debt because, you know, there'd
be no way that you would be able to fund
a lot of this out of your own pocket.
Now, if you can, if you're already rich,
then you can take on raising capital
style big opportunities and then fund it
with your own cash. And that's really an
amazing combination, but not available
to most people. But this allows you to
pursue rarer opportunities. And one of
the advantages of that is that it
actually prices a lot of people out of
the market. So to an degree there is an
element of risk with raising capital
because typically the opportunities that
people pursue are high risk high return
opportunities but there's typically far
fewer competitors and so you know you
can count the number of competitors who
are wellunded even in a space maybe on
two hands. If I said, "How many social
media marketing agencies are there?"
You're going to need a lot more fingers.
And so, within our car analogy example,
you actually just start by building the
car factory. And then, even though you
know you're going to lose money up
front, once the car factory is built,
you know that every single car you're
going to make X dollars of profit,
right? And that is how you end up
recouping it and justifying the return
to the investors. Some of the trade-offs
here are significant. You now have two
customers instead of one. In
bootstrapped, your customer is just the
end customer, right? When you have
raising capital, your customer is both
the end customer and the investors are
venture capitalists. And so that's one
element is that you have to serve two
masters, which can oftenimes be at odds,
which is a bit of a pain. The second
kind of big downside is that you're
going to dilute your own equity. Here
you have 100% of the pie, right?
Whatever you make is yours and that's
your pie. Now, you can give profit
shares, you can give equity slices to
key teammates or partners or whatever.
Um, but they're usually in the business.
They're actually helping you succeed
within the business. Whereas when you're
raising capital, a lot of it's going to
depend on the terms. Chiron, my partner,
tells a story about his first exit ever.
He learned what a ratchet was, which is
that he had a a very large exit in his
first company that he started uh in his
teens that then I think he exited around
age 25. It was many tens of millions of
dollars. But because there were
liquidation preferences uh and ratchets
on those liquidation preferences, the
investors got paid out first and with
some excess. And so when he saw this
very big number, the amount that he and
the other founders were left with was
less. Now, to be fair, he did fine, but
it was less than what he thought he was
going to get. Now, as you continue to
scale this, typically, if you do
multiple rounds, each person who's going
to put money in also wants a seat at the
table, quite literally a board seat,
which means that over time, you can
absolutely get voted out of your own
business, which happened to Steve Jobs,
right? And so, like, these are real
risks that happen like you can lose
control of your own company. And a lot
of this is going to depend on the terms
of other people's money. If someone
gives you a trillion dollars for 1%
equity in your business, that's an
amazing thing. If someone gives you $10
for 90% equity, that's going to be kind
of tough. And so, this one is very much
the devil's in the details. And your
ability to raise is going to be a
combination of two things. Your ability
and track record as a founder and the
size of the opportunity that the
investors believe you're going after and
the likelihood that they believe that
you can actually hit it. And I'll say
the last downside here is that typically
venture money is kind of grand slam
money. It's like they just want you to
swing for the fences and know that
they're going to have a lot of people
strike out. But the economics of having
somebody get a,000x on their money
allows them to have many losses. But if
you're the person who takes the loss and
n equals one as in it's 100% of your
life, that is where the there's a sea of
tombstones of failed ventures and
founders who gave 5 10 plus years of
their life and pretty much worked a job
but with way more stress for a long
period of time and then ended up having
nothing to show for it which is tough
and they don't even have the story of
the big success at the end. So, this is
actually far more common than the big
headlines that we see. And the reason
those things make big headlines is
because they're rare. Which brings me to
the third way of making mega money,
which is investing. Now, this is the one
that probably a lot of people have more
familiarity with, right? It's your money
and you're investing into other people's
businesses, right? So, you take the cash
you earn actively from other places and
then you buy pieces, tiny chunks of
other people's companies. Kind of the
equal opposite of raising capital. Now,
you don't have to buy into venture type
uh products. You can just buy cash
flowing businesses. You can buy public
stocks. uh you can buy real estate.
There's a lot of different things that
you can buy with money. Now, the clear
thing here is that you don't run them,
you fund them. So, me personally, I buy
kind of I'm split in my investing. So, I
have HQ Ventures, which is our venture
arm. So, that's where we we are
basically the raising capital partners
for SMB Tech. And so, that's exclusively
what we invest in because we understand
it well. And then on the other side, we
have kind of the private equity style
investments that we do, but we also add
some sort of service because we have a
whole service layer at ACQ. And so those
are typically more cash flow investment
businesses, but also obviously have
enterprise value. And so who should take
this path? Real quick, I'm going to show
you the exact 10-stage road map from
zero to 100 million plus that less than
1% of companies finish. I've now done
multiple times. And so I can say with a
lot of confidence that these are the
stages as headcount increases that you
need to get through. And I broke each of
these down by eight different functions
of the business. What the constraint
feels like, like what are the symptoms
of it when you're going through it, and
then what steps we actually took to
graduate. And we've done this across
software, physical products, uh, service
businesses, brickandmortar, all of this,
and it works. And it's my gift to you.
It's absolutely free. And so the link's
in the description, but you just go
acquisition.com/roadmap.
Just enter your info and it'll spit it
right back to you. All free. Well, once
you have meaningful excess cash and you
want the upside without the day-to-day
operational responsibility, then this is
an interesting path. And so the main
advantages are that you have
diversification. So you're able to make
many bets instead of kind of a life or
die bet with a single company. But
whenever you uh distribute your bets,
you also decrease your upside, right? So
Dale Carnegie had a famous quote which
is uh put all your eggs in one basket
and then watch the basket. And so that's
him talking about this, right? Boost
wrapping or you're raising capital for
your own business. That's you putting
all your eggs in one basket and trying
like hell to make that thing work. With
investing, you're kind of you're
spreading it out. But when we look at
the most successful investors, they
typically aren't nearly as diversified.
they're typically way more concentrated
which then allows them to may maybe make
five, seven, eight significant bets that
they believe they have alpha or upside
on um above the market. And so with
investing, I think that of the four of
these, arguably the easiest lifestyle
kind of decision because you have no
boss and you're technically other
people's boss and so you just write
checks. You can inform what you want the
person to do. To be clear, you might not
have majority. That's going to depend on
the terms. Um, but when Leila and I sold
the company and we were just a family
office, this is all we did. And I'll say
of my entire life, the most chill
period. And sometimes I think to myself
like, what was I doing? Why am I back
doing this when I don't need to do it
anymore? Um, but I want to make a key
point here is that this is by far the
slowest, number one. And number two,
almost no one makes their money this
way. They have already have a high
active income and then they begin
investing. And if you're like, well, I'm
going to be like Warren Buffett. Well,
did you buy your first stock two weeks
after Pearl Harbor when you were age
seven? No. And did you do it in a world
where there wasn't a Robin Hood and you
actually had to figure out how to do
mail-in ballots and call someone as a
seven-year-old to or 11-year-old,
whatever it was, uh, to make your first
bet? Probably not, because you're like,
I want to be like Mozart and you're age
30 and you want to start investing. It's
like, well, he already had like 19
concertos by this point because he
started at age seven. So, I wouldn't
say, oh, let me look at what the top
person in this field did if you're not
that person. And so the whole point of
this video is to figure out what path is
right for you. And to be clear, Warren
Buffett is very famous now, but like
until he was 60, I don't think many
people even knew his name, 60, right?
And he's made the vast majority of his
wealth from like age 80 to 95. So think
how crazy that is. So if you're like,
I'm in this for the very very very very
very very
long haul, then this is a good path for
you. And especially if you're somebody
who wants a little bit more of a
lifestyle um where you're like, "Okay, I
just have to get my my passive to exceed
my active costs," then it's like great.
And if you get better and better at that
game, you'll have more and more and then
you'll have nothing else to do and
you'll just keep playing the game just
for the love of the game. But it does
take time. It's unlikely that you're
going to get these 50, you know, 50%
100% plus annual returns. Even Warren
for a very long time didn't get those
types of returns. And even in the
beginning, he was still combating, I
think, 50-ish% um but he was the best in
the world. And then once he had more
capital, his returns decreased. And a
great note on this is that in in I would
say Main Street, real estate is the
number one most common path for creating
millionaires, but not the most common
path for creating billionaires. And to
me, that is kind of like a great kind of
cherry on top for this little bucket,
which is that it is a great way to build
and store wealth. It's being smart with
your money and allocating it
appropriately. It's unlikely to be the
thing that gets you all the way to the
top unless you have a very, very long
time horizon. And let's be real, you
have to live to 95 like Warren Buff to
hit the list. Like that's real. Like
Charlie Mer was 99 when he died. And so
like in a very real way like they had
like if they had died at 74, I don't
know if we talk about them as much
because they wouldn't have had all the
compounding that happened after. So like
this is a long long game.
Finally, that leads us to number four,
which is fund management.
So this is you take other people's money
and you invest it in other people's
businesses. You raise a pool of capital
for investors, which is the fancy word
that has LPs or limited partners, and
then you use that money to buy pieces or
control of other people's businesses.
Now, depending on the way that you do
it, you can also use debt there, too.
So, let me give you a visual of like
this is potentially one of the highest
leverage scenarios. It's like this on
steroids, basically. And so, let's say
that you want to you want to raise $100
million. Now, I'm going to use big
numbers because I want you to think
bigger anyways rather than thinking in
small numbers. All right? So, in order
for you to raise a fund with $100
million, it's typical that the person
who raises the fund puts about 5% of the
total funds raised in. So, you put $5
million in. You raise $95 million of LP
capital. That means limited partner
capital. So, other people put their
money in. And then, this is where it
gets even crazier. So, this is $100
million in total, right? But then you
say, you know what? We're going to go
buy I don't have enough space on this
thing, so just bear with me. uh we're
going to buy $300 million
of businesses because we're going to use
200 million
in debt
to buy these businesses. And so think
about the leverage that you get from
your $5 million able to buy $300 million
worth of stuff. Now, when this $300
million, let's say it just grows at 10%
a year. Let's say you're not amazing.
You're just matching the S&P. All right?
In seven years, you'll double, right?
So, this is now $600 million 7 years
later. Now, if you had a 10% return for
private equity, that would be bad. But
I'm just going to give you like the base
case of like you're not that good at
this. Okay? So, that means that you have
a $300 million delta. So, we got to pay
back, right? We got to pay back the
debt. So, we have to take our $200
million out because we got to pay the
debtors back. Now, they have some
interest and some other stuff there,
too, right? Then, we got to pay our LPs
back, right? I'm just making the box a
little bit smaller so I can draw the
rest of it. All right? So, we got to
take we got to take this back. Now
sometimes there's a hurdle rate which is
a minimum return you give these guys
saying I don't get paid until X happens
that depends but typically in private
equity it's 6 to 8% somewhere in there
and then whatever is left over here you
then have a split with them LPS and then
GPU. So let's see what happens when you
actually invest this money and then wait
5 to 7 years. Now, let's say because
you're in private equity and you're
investing in non-public markets, you get
a better than public market return,
which is basically the baseline. Like,
no one wants to get a public equity
return and have their money locked up
for, you know, 5 to seven years. So, if
you got a 20% annualized return for 6
years, you would have 2.98 on the money.
So, functionally, your 300 million,
right, that you bought now becomes 900
million. Oo,
more.
All right. So, we got to pay back our
debt. So, we have our 200 million that
we got to pay back in debt. Now, there's
going to be some interest on that. Let's
say that we got to pay them back um $100
million in
debt payments. Okay? So, we have that
that too. Now, we also have our LP's $95
million that they put in. So, we got to
pay them back that. And then there's
some minimum return that we promise them
before we participate, which for us is
going to be about $40 million if we have
a 6% pref or hurdle that goes back to
them. So that is all guaranteed to them.
Now after that, it just depends purely
on the nature of the the asset class and
what you're investing in and your kind
of proprietary blend of whatever.
There's going to be some split of the
profits here that goes to you, the GP,
the general partner. That's the
operating partner, the person who runs
the whole fund. and then some that goes
to the LP or limited partner. And so
let's say that you had a 5050 split
here, let's just call it. Okay, that
means that after we add all of this
stuff up, this slice here is $465
million.
Remember, we started with 5 million.
This is how you get mega rich. Now, to
be clear, all this isn't yours. Maybe
twothirds of that isn't yours. But
either way, even if you had 10% of that
and you got $46.5 million,
you did pretty good on your $5 million
investment, right? If you got 20%, now
you're looking at $90 million. Even
better on your $5 million investment.
You see how this stuff adds up? And
that's because this is leverage. Now,
when we look back at our original kind
of sheet here
with each of these four paths, you have
to decide on what's best for you. If you
have some proprietary way that you know
how to source deals and you have a good
way of finding capital, which by the
way, if you're like, I don't know how to
raise capital. You absolutely do know
how to raise capital if you have good
deals. One of the best pieces of advice
I got from a mentor of mine is that
there is no lack of capital in the
world, only a lack of good deals. And
so, if you find a good deal, capital
will appear. Right? If you come to me
and say I have a guaranteed way, which
of course don't use those words, uh
because that's a great way to get get
good money to run away. But if you're
like, there is an incredibly high
likelihood chance that I have of 5xing
money in this way, and here's the six
different ways that I've mitigated the
risk. And let's say those are
believable. And if we have that, then
I'd be like, okay, well, how much money
do you need? And that's how any good
investor is going to ask the question
because when you do identify good
opportunities, you just want to back up
the truck. Now, in that setting, the
higher, believe it or not, the higher
the return and the more private the type
of deal that you're doing that's more
niche and specific to what you know,
typically the better the splits that you
can negotiate on the GPL split of the
profits after some certain point. And
so, who should do this? I think the best
like version of this is where you build
a track record. You figure out
proprietary deal flows and deal flow
that only comes to you that no one else
has. And you have some sort of real edge
in picking and improving those
companies. So oftentimes funds are are
organized around a a singular thesis. So
for example, at the very beginning of
acquisition.com, I got approached by a
walnut tree fund. I was like, I don't
even know this exists. But they
explained how it worked, which is like
it takes 30 years to grow a black walnut
tree all the way to like full size. But
every year after year three, it creates
walnuts. And so it cash flows every
single year. And then at the end of the
30 years, you cut the walnut tree down
and you get this amazing walnut wood
that you can then sell. And then the
cost is really just the seeds and the
time. And that was their entire business
model. And they'd done this a number of
times and they had these kind of
staggered uh tree vintages if you I'm
using the wrong word, but like the
vintage of trees. Every year they had
another cohort. And I was like, this is
a really interesting business. And they
had a fund around it because I don't
want to know where the Venezuelan tree
farmers are. I don't have those
connections. I don't know how to sell
walnuts at scale. Could I figure it out?
Maybe. Is it worth my time? Probably
not. Is it worth my money? If it doesn't
take my time, maybe. And so the beauty
of this one is that you have maximum
leverage and you can have the smallest
personal checks. You have huge
potentials for upside. Um there's also
fees that you can put onto this.
Typically, uh the better and the more
track record you have, more you can add
fees in. I'd say your first time often
times you have less fees, uh just
because you want people to come in and
not think you're going to get rich on
the fees. They want to have as as
aligned incentives as possible with the
investor. Now, often times the GP ends
up richer than any single LP. obviously
depends on how much capital gets put in
um that they that they take from. Now
the risks you have enormous
responsibility and a very long feedback
loop and you're accountable to the LPs
and to regulators and to the
entrepreneurs are running the businesses
and to some degree the customers that
those businesses serve and so you have a
lot of masters to serve in this time
period. Um and you can be rich on paper
but the entire time you almost feel like
a slave which sucks. And so your job
becomes managing risk and reputation and
people and portfolios, not just building
one company. And if anything, you're
almost building the company of the fund.
So I got rich bootstrapping my
companies. I took some of my cash and
invested in other people's companies.
That cash continued to compound um and I
was able to invest and then co-found
school where we raised capital. I
obviously promote school as well. And
then finally, it's in fund management.
So uh we've raised capital for some of
the real estate deals that we've done
when we buy big buildings uh which we do
through ACQ. uh real estate. We've only
done that privately to some of our
higher level uh clients and portfolio
companies. We are functionally general
partners in some big real estate
buildings which you can check out
acquisition.com real estate. But yeah,
these are the four ways to make mega
money. Pick the path that's right for
you.